enfin
[Musique]
en
bas en haut
la danse c'est vraiment avec toutes ces
années de travail le langage universel
le langage qui nous ramène dans nos
émotions et nos émotions sont communes
elles sont humaines aux émissions
humaines donc plus plus je travaille
plus sains et parce que je me rends
compte là dedans c'est vraiment un art
qui permet une première conversation
entre les hommes puisqu'elle n'est ni
dans le verbe décliné dans le dans le
conflit elle et elle passe par les
émotions et on est et on les connaît
tous celle qu'on peut décrire celle
qu'on peut prononcer et celle qu'on ne
peut même pas expliqué
[Musique]
oh
j'ai commencé mes mes premiers pas au
sermac et le sermac c'était déjà un
mouvement de l'avant garde sur
l'universalité bon créé par aimé césaire
dirigé par jean-paul césaire on ne
pouvait pas être plus dans cette
démarche
déjà le sermac y avait on parle du parc
floral où il y avait des ateliers de
toutes sortes de formes d'art céramique
poterie vannerie musique ou d'où
viennent beaucoup d'entre nous un c'est
de là qu'on a tous beaucoup tous
commencent et où s'entrecroisent et
légendes est notable dans énorme et où
il y avait toujours ses productions une
ou deux fois par an ou tous et harvey
revenait se rassembler dirigée par un
l'autre est souvent roger robinet loup
expo d'autres personnes est vraiment
donc quand on est enfant et quand on est
baigné dans ce une chose qui se faisait
sous louis xiv déjà de ramener tous les
tous les arts donc c'est vraiment pour
moi ça m'imprégner de la non limite sam
a imprégné de la non séparation donc
avec le temps je j'ai de plus en plus de
mal à supporter la séparation
puisqu'elle les limitations
je préfère l'universel qui amène à la
création et les racines pour répondre à
ta question
les racines on ne peut être bien dans le
dialogue avec l'autre quand on sait d'où
vient donc dans son nid dans quand on
est bien dans son identité quand on ne
ment pas sur son identité quand on
reconnaît ses racines singulière au
pluriel
on peut commencer une conversation dans
la paix